und ich begrüße jetzt ganz herzlich den
csu politiker manfred weber
fraktionsvorsitzender der europäischen
volkspartei im eu-parlament herr weber
nachdem die erzwungene flugzeug landung
in linz bekannt wurde haben sie ja per
twitter gefordert die eu müsse darauf
schnell und entschieden reagieren
reicht ihnen nun diese reaktion darauf
die vom gipfel der staats und
regierungschefs ausgeht
die staats und regierungschefs haben in
dieser nacht ein starkes signal
ausgesandt dass sofort reagiert worden
ist
man muss sich ja den sachverhalt noch
mal vergegenwärtigen es geht um einen
flug innerhalb der europäischen union
zwischen zwei mitgliedsstaaten der eu
griechenland und litauen
es geht um einen europäischen flug
betreiber eine fluggesellschaft ryanair
die betroffen sind und insofern zeigt
der vorgang dass lukaschenko und belarus
nicht ein externes problem sind sondern
ein problem für uns alle sind in der
europäischen union
und deswegen sind die entscheidungen gut
sie müssen jetzt aber auch mit leben
gefüllt werden gerade was die konkrete
liste der sanktionen betrifft dann
lassen sie uns noch mal über die
konkreten maßnahmen sprechen weil airbus
soll nun auch vom europäischen
flugverkehr im grunde abgeschnitten
werden damit werden ja aber nicht nur
die bestraft die bestraft werden sollen
also aus eu sicht sondern auch andere
die ganz normale zivilbevölkerung das
kann und das auch nicht das ziel sein
oder die abgrenzung ist zugegebenermaßen
extrem schwer wann immer wir sanktionen
beschließen ist damit auch verbunden
dass die menschen das im alltag spüren
wir müssen versuchen jetzt vor allem bei
der listung der der machthaber die das
system lukaschenka in belarus
stabilisieren dass wir da sehr präzise
vorgehen aber gewisse wirkungen auch auf
die bürgerschaft auf die mitten auf die
menschen wird es geben
es gibt aber dazu leider gottes keine
alternative also wenn wir sehen dass
lukaschenko mit brutaler macht sein
system stabilisiert sein oligarchische
system versucht über die runden zu
retten muss man reagieren und das hat
dann auch konsequenzen für den alltag
der menschen aber von den bisherigen
sanktionen zeigte sich belarus zu wenig
beeindruckt also was kann man wirklich
erreichen und
wie groß ist auch die gefahr dass die eu
weiter an bedeutungen an glaubwürdigkeit
in ihrer außenpolitik verliert wenn
alles so weiterläuft wie die europäische
union würde zunächst einmal an
glaubwürdigkeit verlieren wenn wir nicht
reagieren
man muss ja diese mutige menschen sehen
die in druck und in belarus in den
letzten monaten auf die straße gegangen
sind
neben dem blogger der jetzt festgenommen
worden ist legt sind tausende in
gefängnissen in belarus weil sie für
ihre freiheit eingetreten sind und das
größere bild das wir uns immer
vergegenwärtigen müssen ist dass die
idee von freiheit von demokratie und von
rechtsstaatlichkeit immer mehr menschen
überzeugt und gewinnt und richtung osten
sich vor kämpft diese idee und das
größere problem dass hinter lukaschenko
steht ist natürlich moskau ist natürlich
putin
lukaschenko hat sich klar für den
russischen weg entschieden
zur unterdrückung der eigenen
bürgerinnen und bürger und auch in
russland sehen wir mittlerweile und mit
vielen mutigen menschen eine bewegung
die für freiheit eintritt und deswegen
glaubwürdigkeit europas entsteht indem
wir signalisieren wir stehen an eurer
seite
andererseits muss man auch klar sagen
dass wir die inneren entwicklungen in
belarus und in russland nicht von außen
gestalten können jetzt müssen schon
bewegungen seien die aus dem inneren
hervorkommen und ich hoffe dass sie
stark genug sind dass auch belarus den
demokratischen und freiheitlichen weg
geht das heißt aber auch alle reaktionen
der mitteiler gesagt vor allem die
reaktion der eu ist wichtig wenn die
reaktion aber die ganzen maßnahmen
verpuffen welche möglichkeiten gibt es
denn da noch den weg einer gesellschaft
hin zu freiheit und demokratie kann man
nicht von außen erzwingen
man kann deutlich machen wir stehen an
der seite dieser mutigen vor allem
jungen menschen das ist die aufgabe die
wir jetzt zu zu tätigen haben und eben
nach dem vorfall von gestern mit dem
erzwungenen landung der ryanair-maschine
müssen wir klarstellen ist es nicht mehr
nur um eine außenpolitische frage
sondern eine politische frage ist
betrifft uns europäer ganz praktisch ob
wir uns sicher sind wenn wir in einem
flieger uns befinden ob er diesem
staatsterrorismus ausgeliefert sind oder
nicht und deswegen werde die aktion
jetzt richtig ich möchte aber den blick
wirklich nochmal weiter richtung
russland wir haben dort ein jahr
die klare aussage dass man an der seite
von lukaschenko steht und deswegen
müssen wir auch moskau in den blick
nehmen
nach den entwicklungen beispielsweise
der desinformationskampagne im inneren
europas der morde die auf berliner
straßen in der auftrag von putin verübt
worden sind bis hin zur ukraine der krim
besetzung oder syrien wo es hat ein
massenmörder seines eigenen volkes mit
putins unterstützung an der macht
gehalten wurde
wenn wir die ganze liste sehen dann muss
uns klar werden dass russland sich einen
anti freiheitlichen anti demokratischen
kurs verschrieben hat und das heißt
entschiedenheit das heißt klarheit in
unserem ansatz gegenüber russland und da
hoffe ich dass es gelingt dass europa
beisammen bleibt wir haben einzelne
mitgliedstaaten der europäischen union
die mit einem russland freundlicheren
kurs ja sympathisieren und ich hoffe
dass wir als europäer entschieden sind
in unserer klaren botschaft richtung
moskau die ihr geht den falschen weg
bitte bitte kehrt um
herr weber ich möchte auch noch mit ihm
über andere themen sprechen die ja auch
auf der agenda dieses gipfels stehen zum
beispiel das klimaziel für 2030
mindestens 55 prozent weniger ausstoß
von treibhausgasen im vergleich zum jahr
1990 und weil das ziel bis 2030 nicht
pauschal für jeden mitgliedsstaat gilt
soll es nun um die lastenverteilung
gehen da es ja klar das streitpotenzial
ist enorm oder als ein extra ich mich
dass wir europäer uns diesem 55 prozent
ziel jetzt verschrieben haben bis 20.30
das bedeutet noch mal deutlich deutlich
verstärkte ambition die europäer zeigen
und das ist notwendig und richtig in der
welt von heute
bei der lastenverteilung darf sich
niemand rausnehmen und rausrechnen jeder
muss seinen beitrag leisten allerdings
ist auch klar dass vor allem die
westlichen industrienationen
technologische führerschaft übernehmen
müssten
wir brauchen ideen gebrauchten
kreativität es wird nicht einfach nur
mit abschalten von anlagen getan sein
sondern wir brauchen moderne
technologien um die sich im klima die
sich veränderungen mit klima zu
schultern und anzugehen und deswegen
braucht so gute mischung
für mich ist wichtig dass wir
technologieneutral an die aufgaben
herangehen es ist nicht aufgabe von
politik
technologien zu verbieten und das zweite
wir müssen marktwirtschaftlich an die
aufgaben herangehen nicht
ordnungspolitisch vorschreiben was zu
tun ist sondern der markt findet die
beste lösung um die ziele zu erreichen
und deswegen marktwirtschaftlichen
ansatz sagt manfred weber ich bedanke
mich ganz herzlich für dieses gespräch
ich bedanke mich